il est avec nous ce soir
applaudissements pour renverser
[Applaudissements]
monomakh on a un petit truc pour toi
parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui est à
l'essai à une vidéo quitte à laisser un
petit message à bout pas je pense que
vous avez de reconnaître et que tu vois
le reconnaître regarde
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien jouer avec vos mains
parce que c'est une bonne personne qui
essaie toujours donner le meilleur à son
entourage et à lui-même ne considérais
comme mon papa parce que vous donnez
plus du conseil et en plus lui les vous
faire beaucoup rire les gens s'y sont
mortes et une personne généreuse
affectueuse et modeste vais m'acheter ma
plus profonde manquer et que je ne
t'oublierai jamais je te souhaite le
maire et guy même que tu dépasses miss
miss
[Applaudissements]
deuxièmement parce que je ne sais pas si
les regarde mais moi aussi je laime au
plus profond de mon coeur c'est un
moment extraordinaire il est il est
malin il est très attachant c'est voilà
je laime aussi alors la vidéo n'est pas
finie parce que regarde il a un petit
truc est demandée comment l'effacer
m'ont posé une question de la plus haute
importance
il veut savoir si tu danses et bien en
valeur et je les ai dit que tu te sens
mieux que moi alors au moins te plaît
fais moi un honneur
et après s'il a dansé et das
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas qu'il me demandait un non
alors nous battre avec nos petites à
utiliser jusqu'à ce que je veux pas
donner ses lecteurs je commence à en
avoir assez haut mais on a vu qu'on
entend ça fait une vingtaine d'années et
c'est comme ça que tu meurs
[Applaudissements]
enfin
[Musique]
oula
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va aller
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le maillon
fort
[Musique]
si vous répondez bien tout va bien si
vous répondez mal aux marques tu vas
tenir à côté de moi tu as pure à turin
sur doha de ses boutons comme l'a fait
christian clavier la semaine dernière
omar dia cotée morts lacavera attention
bernard montiel se sont que des
questions sur omar sy a mais restions
top
combien d'enfants as omar sy combien de
fois omar sy 5,5
c'est une bonne réponse réponse pas de
réponse qu'un grand acteur américain
oscarisé a déclaré qu'ils n'arrivaient
pas à la cheville d'omar sy médailles
[Musique]
s'est perdue benhaim annette est gentil
et et tom hanks est tom hanks grands
comptes
oui tom hanks il a dit atlas est là je
reprends la classe hanouna là c'est à
duda qui vous parle il a fait un il a
fait des éloges sur thomas et il a dit
que vous aviez tourné ensemble c'est
vrai on l'a on s'appelle dans l'isère
inferno ans et la suite de davinci code
et il a dit qu'ils ne tarit vais pas à
la cheville
c'est enfin très poliment non non non
l'autre regardez regardez garder sinon
j'aimerais bien pouvoir être polyvalent
mais alors à côté de marc si je n'arrive
pas à la cheville
mais c'est absolument tout faire c'est
un acteur absolument époustouflant
extraordinaire c'est une inspiration
premier avec nous
la divine et déjà il ya fait pas chez
omar qui a fait passer aux marrons un
célèbre footballeur sénégalais pour lui
permettre de travailler sur radio nova
diabète vous exactement
c'était anodin merci d'être venus c'est
vrai que cette vidéo est folle c'est que
est ce que tu peux nous raconter encore
on adore harper a coûté 15 fois mon kiff
avait quoi va parce que omar en fait il
a il a dit en fait que pour ta première
émission il devait inviter il invité
nicolas anelka qui était un grand espoir
du foot et toi omar est en fait il était
encore au lycée tu prépare un bac pro
chauffage et climatisation de dire ça
mais alléchant mi journée on a tous
besoin de chauffage et de climat c'est
vrai c'est vrai j'ai dû encore et il
inventait la carrière de futurs grands
footballeurs sénégalais sidy viendront
service g j'ai besoin de donner un
deuxième invité sac souvenu qu'il avait
lui donné un autre un autre joueur un
autre joueur
il a fait passer pour un jour soit
rédigé deux invités et un joueur
sénégalais incroyants pis il s'est
reconverti à la cud du fait sauter avec
nicolas datas viol est posée avec
annonça hall et puis il a ri et j'ai pas
prévenu les jaunes la radio que c'était
un stade jamais lâché n'a jamais lâché
vous êtes maître très potes toujours
tous les hommes feraient rufin gros
bisous à tiaret quelles chansons des
années 80 omar et moi avons nous chanter
ensemble de l'ess avait fait perdre les
démons de minuit
mais il a dit même mois chez telus
magique de catherine lara
avant d'écrire la bande expert
aromatique aux non halal c'est la belle
boutique c'est pas pour ça qu'on paye
pas je peux tourner de ce qu'on paye lui
mais j on paie le mémoire au fond d'un
tiroir convient lesouëf nous et bah si
t'es pas du tiroir t'es pas de même pas
laisser n'importe quoi tu dis n'importe
quoi oui bah à 6,2 pas le s'allume en à
moi c'est pas cher pas des tiroirs arize
savoir d'où nous rôle nous échappe
chelou c'est sur le mois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gilles verdez omar sy la jouer dans le
clip d'un célèbre groupe breton tel est
le nom de ce groupe
ouais j'ai perdu et perdu verdez et même
moi je le savais pas là je les suis là à
nous webamanu aller il a joué il y avait
également vincent desagnat sur brad face
à l'avenir est un long passé c'était le
tout
mano baïse à effet la tribu de dana mais
sur ce rappel
[Musique]
à
passé
[Musique]
placé à quelques pas de là des allemands
1944 jean marc est un résistant
ils avaient pour mission de faire sonner
chemin de fer lui qu'il n'est pas un
mode d'action est devenu maître de
guerre après le cyclone qui frappe par
sa mère et son père d'une étoile jaune
était venu droit de l'enfer il ay la
peau et je suis sûr il est rentré chez
lui il a dû faire ça y est je joue dans
une équipe de man où il est tombé
journée de tournage la veille au lit on
sort soit nos deux matches et une
journée c'est beau la mer c'est bon j'ai
une journée le ouf
le clip avec manolo lévesque ce soir ce
que l'animal au mars y at-il la phobie
est phobie des serpents
non ce n'est pas les avoir fugué nord
je ne dis pas le dit pas non plus renier
le pas la pub de là alors si le bac
jeudi l'invité roi des quoi il y aura
beau c'est grand c'est calme en france
elle a deux mois non mais t'as pas peur
des narines pourquoi mais c'est rien
abîmer mise par ailleurs quoi ça
s'explique pas non j'ai rêvé unat d'une
araignée cette nuit salut c'est bizarre
je suis là bah oui je te jure j'ai rêvé
d'une araignée cette nuit et elle
rentrait partout partout partout
oui je vous jure mais elle est grosse
une non innus apalon n'approuve pas ce
qu'on met ce que je vais fort boyard
2006 ah ben oui oui ça va te mettre en
valeur franchement je fais ce que tu
veux mais je n'avais pas mes amis
on n'est pas et alors quand je mets pas
ce qui veut dire économie en vrai c'est
l'été le nom de l'ancêtre du sav d'omar
et fred se disant dans plus clair
présenté par daphné roulier des appuis
ça se voit que tu sois amistad matin
pourquoi pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la réforme et de barzani avec une star
de la saga des rocky mais ouais ouais
c'est vrai dans ses tâches ans un
documentaire sur toi qu'on peut voir
actuellement sur les antennes de canal
plus un documentaire exceptionnel sur
roma on apprend que tu es quand tu étais
jeune fille était archi fan d'euros qui
énonce les jeunes maintenant je sais
mais comment ou sur apollo creed sera
pas d'ailleurs il ya eu là qui vient de
sortie et le sait le papa du personnage
voilà que de creed 2 et la sortie de
tout ça vous êtes devenus très très
proches
regardez et juste après on va parler
justement de ces cubes honneur on va
jouer pour c'est que du bonheur grâce
apollo creed ces parties semblent à ça
il est là il a adoré fille mais trouve
ça super qu'après tout simple je fasse
ça et moi je me dis du mal à dire que
c'est lui qui est là qui connaît mon
travail qui m'ont parle comme ça c'est
compliqué tu vois tu imagines bien je
lâche plus après bah ouais vient pour se
voit bien on parle est donc maintenant
je bois des cafés avec lui je fais une
fête j'invite je suis fan évidemment je
suis forgé jubile avec lui je suis comme
un gamin devant son idole sera donc
vraiment je suis excité pour lui c'est
non alors omar hier c'était ton
anniversaire
c'est vrai donc déjà je voudrais faire
un gros bisou à ce stade
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
oh bah voilà
[Musique]
on marque deux a été élue la
personnalité préférée des français en
2016 et cette année tu en deuxième
position il ya jean jacques goldman en
avant toi mais tu es toujours dans les
trois premiers et c'est vrai que ici
voilà moi je suis moi tu es un pote mais
c'est vrai que voilà si j'avais dû voter
pour quelqu'un je pense que j'aurais
voté pour toi c'est gentil j'aime
beaucoup j'ai quand même mais je connais
pas personnellement
il fait là dans la foi dans la rue y
marcher seule échelle en bois soit la
personne mise adore la personne je ne le
connais pas mais vraiment je suis fan de
tdu régaler mais c'est vrai que j'aurais
voté pour toi et donc vous aussi vous
allez me dire voilà pour qu'ils vous
auriez voter vous tiens d'ailleurs pas
franchement aubin au bar où elle m'a
vraiment mais on marque plus il est
fédérateur et non la jeunesse et tout ça
vous choque pas paul selmer le
footballeur ah ben je sais mercredi
c'est qu'il faut d'ailleurs pas non plus
voilà tu vois je
celui qui fait des wii vous a remercié à
la fois le charisme il est resté proche
des gens ont le centre c'est vrai c'est
cet attelage là c'est formidable je vous
le jure est vraiment au mas il n'a pas
changé c'est un truc de ouf et c'est
nouveau fait moi quand je le vois j'ai
tendance un peu au départ à faire joujou
au maintien non mais t'as pas remarqué
est ce que c'est vrai aux mains ou pas
que les mecs parce que c'est pas toi qui
a changé mais tu es devenu une telle
star ouais c'est que moi mais moi voilà
t'y connais bien je te jure et où quand
j'arrive demande au départ qui fait non
attends et omar qui arrivent jusqu'au
bout avec des potes des fruits qu'en
fait toujours les mêmes pas non plus
indiqué qu'elle avait il ya vingt ans et
est ce que tu sens quand même qu'à ya
ainsi si les gens voient le taux de
change pas mais qui a un petit une
petite gêne non sont pas de jeunes - non
mais parce qu'on aime et il sait ce
qu'on a on est on est un peu hautain est
ce que tu sens que tu pas pu
impressionner des gens ouais mais ça ça
rien à voir c'est le charisme de toi
quand même vous vous auriez dit qu'ils
vous quelqu'un est vivant oui je vais
dire au marasquin puces rfid la non oui
d'abord j'aime beaucoup associé à
taurines films fins utiles et l'a6 avait
été bonne
wyss avait été contraint coleman si vous
auriez droit commun new yorkais des
pauvres donc on comprend bien mais moi
j'aurai moi je redis pareil j'aurais dit
jean jacques goldman n'a pas changé en
tout cas je sais pas si vous avez
beaucoup dormi ce week-end mais là
j'étais même nom mais ni son geste aux
rouges n'ont pas les autres rouges dette
et fatigue alors je vous le dis je vous
adore de coiffure vous êtes blanc comme
un cul
rien que ça prendrait vous m'avez envoyé
une tonne de mousse à raser ya vu
j'étais dès ma quille est exact c'est un
petit peu seul m'a nommé à l'abri de
trouver quelqu'un sans hésiter une
seconde
qui pour le sourire parce que c'est un
artiste pour ses valeurs et pour son
corps et en espérant qu' un petit peu
d'ambiguïté omar alors ont voté pour toi
alors 5e l'ambiguïté vous pouvez
l'enlever
il adore il respecte tout le monde il
adore l'amitié à mais voilà il est
intouchable
[Applaudissements]